frauen in roth güter als scheuklappen
wie die märkte aus dem kultroman report
der markt auch bekannt als and mainstay
längst sind sie symbol auf weltweiten
demonstrationen für die rechte von
frauen
ob in der türkei in argentinien oder
gegen das sogenannte herzschlag gesetz
in texas das strengste abtreibungsgesetz
in den usa
jeder der bei der planung oder umsetzung
einer abtreibung hilft kann angeklagt
werden wer den notiert wird belohnt bei
schuldspruch bekommen die klagenden die
10.000 dollar die die verurteilten
zahlen müssen
das gesetz ist eine absolut treffsichere
waffe um frauen fertig zu machen
du kennst jemanden ohne beweise
beschuldigen
das gesetz beinhaltet auch das vorhaben
eine abtreibung wie sollst du beweisen
dass du es nicht vorhat ist oder gar
nicht schwanger war
das ist schwierig
außerdem appelliert das gesetz an die
gier wenn du wohlhabende menschen ins
visier nimmst bekommst du er die 10.000
dollar belohnung auch ohne sie
anzuzeigen das gesetz ist ein perfektes
instrument für bestechung und erpressung
methoden wie in report der magd margaret
atwood wälster der kanadischen literatur
veröffentlichte den internationalen
bestseller schon 1985 ein dystopische
roman über ein amerika der zukunft in
dem religiöse fanatiker eine diktatur
namens gilead errichten
frauen sind bloß darum zu dienen und zu
gebären
selbstbestimmtes leben nur noch eine
erinnerung die gegenwart unabhängiger
frauen von heute ist für die frauen von
gilead vergangenheit
der roman zeigt wie fragil sicher
geglaubte freiheiten sind ob als graphic
novel oder als millionenfach gesehene
serie der stoff so aktuell wie vor 30
jahren und genauso erfolgreich
justice erst 2019 erscheint adwords
fortsetzung vom report der markt die
zeugin
nachdem die rechte unabhängiger frauen
lange gesichert schienen löste die trump
regierung eine neue welle an interessant
[Musik]
die gesellschaft ändert sich ebenso die
art wie wir literatur lesen so haben
sich auf die bücher verändert
der roman sei keine science-fiction sagt
edward sondern speculation
alles schon so oder ähnlich passiert die
schriftstellerin recherchierte sie in
der weltgeschichte gelehrt totalitäre
maßnahmen nach der machtergreifung
werden frauen sofort entlassen ihre
konten gesperrt
sie mussten das so machen compo konnten
und jobs in einem rutsch stell dir vor
wie es sonst gerade auf den flughäfen
zuging sie wollen auf keinen fall dass
wir abbauen
worte von 1985
die bilder vom flughafen in kabul sie
sind wenige wochen alt
es ist nur die wiederholung eines
musters das abläuft wann immer
politisches chaos
es gibt die möglichkeit rauszukommen
jeder rennt einige schaffen es weil sie
schnell sind dann bekommen die
machthaber die situation in den griff
werden organisierter in berlin etwa
bauten sie eine mauer
und natürlich will ein regime wie gilead
schnellstmöglich ins geld
leider haben wir jetzt die technischen
mittel dafür geschaffen um das einfacher
möglich zu machen
gesellschaftspolitische fragen der kern
ihres schaffens sie setzt sich ein vor
allem für die freiheit der frauen und
die rettung des planeten dieses jahr
halten waldbrände kanada in atem
zerstören ganzer landstriche nicht von
klimawandel sondern von klimakrise einem
notfall sprich mehr bewusstsein für den
planeten schaffen dafür kämpfte und
kämpft sie wie die neue weltweite
bewegung heute
ich liebe diese menschen sind weil sie
jung sind sie werden das ruder rumreißen
weil sie bald will
dessen sollten sich politiker du bist
nur in kanada ist wirklich groß wenn du
davon aus dass du unendliche ressourcen
dann wirst du verschwenderischer mit
kanada exportiert vor allem rohstoffe wo
bekommst du die hält
zum beispiel fisch wer ist für kanadier
schon immer ein großes thema
früher wurden wir dafür verspottet so
viel an fisch zu denken aber jetzt
begreift die welt langsam wie kostbar
fisch ist
der grund warum deutschland so scharf
auf erneuerbare energien ist
ist doch klar
das nach ihr benannte adjektiv edwardian
steht für einen ironisch hellsichtigen
zukunftsblick
komplex sind ihre werke aber auch
unterhaltsam oder wie sie selbst sagt
spaß ist nicht zu verachten
besonders in kanada nicht
wenn du keine freude an deiner umgebung
hast hast du nicht darauf auf um etwas
zu bewahren musst du investieren und das
bedeutet du musst freude haben
kein spaß wäre es zum beispiel
aufzuhören zu atmen das wäre kein spaß
und deshalb sollten wir sehr auf die
fische achten wir müssen auf unsere
ozeane aufpassen weil wir von ihnen den
meisten sauerstoff bekommt
vergnügen bereiten ein spiegel der
gesellschaft sein ja sogar die welt
verändern das alles kann literatur wie
margaret atwood eindrucksvoll zeigt
[Musik]